مساء الخير الاقتصاد السري هو باختصار
الاقتصاد غير الرسمي والاقتصاد غير الرسمي
هو كل الانشطه صناعيه
والزراعيه كل الانشطه الحقيقه وانشطه
المقاولات كل الانشطه التي لا تخضع لرقابه
الدوله وبالتالي لا تدفع ضرائب عن نشاط
هذا هو الاقتصاد غير الرسمي وبهذا التعريف
يبقى الاقتصاد السري او الاقتصاد غير
الرسمي بيشمل ايضا ما يسمى بالاقتصاد
الاسود اللي هو بيشير الى
الانشطه الغير مشروعه او المحرمه قانونا
زي تجاره المخدرات والدعاره وخلافه لانها
برضو انشطه لا تخضع لرقابه الدوله بطبيعه
الحال وبالتالي لا تدفع ضرائب ولا يتم
مراقبتها من خلال اجهزه الدوله المختل
ملفه الانشطه دي الاقتصاد غير الرسمي اللي
هو موجود في كثير جدا من دول العالم
الثالث او الدول الناميه وبتعاني منه بشده
منتشر في كثير من دول العالم وليه شكلين
اساسيين الشكل الاكبر هي المؤسسات التي لا
تخضع كما قلت لرقابه الدوله والشكل الثاني
هو العمال او الموظفون اللي بيشتغلوا في
مؤسسات كبيره ومحترمه ومسجله وتدفع ضرائب
وبعدها مدرك في اسواق المال لكنهم يعملون
بدون عقود حتى في الحكومات نفسها في
الاجهزه الحكوميه يبقى عامل متعاقد في
بيعمل في شركه كبيره او حتى داخل الجهاز
الاداري للدوله لكنه يعمل بصوره غير بشكل
غير رسمي لانه غير متعاقد وبالتالي على
الورق او نظريا الدوله لا تعرف عنه اي شيء
لو خدنا مصر
كحاله لتوضيح حجم الاقتصاد غير الرسمي او
الاقتصاد السري هتجد ان مصر من الدول وهي
ليست الدوله الوحيده من الدول اللي
الاقتصاد غير الرسمي متضخم فيها بشكل كبير
جدا بحيث انه يكاد يكون دوله داخل الدوله
الاقتصاد غير الرسمي في مصر التقديرات فيه
بتتنوع على حسب الدراسه اللي بتتعمل عليه
يعني في دراسات وفي باحثين بيحددوا حجم
هذا الاقتصاد غير الرسمي باكتر من 60% من
الاقتصاد من حجم الناتج القومي طب حجم
الناتج القومي في مصر قد ايه للتسهيل
حوالي 240 مليون دولار يعني بتتكلم على
1.4 من تريليون جنيه مصري ما يعادل 60% من
هذا الرقم اقتصاد لا تعرف عنه الدوله اي
شيء ناخد امثله كل الباعه الجائلين
والباعه السريحه اللي بيملوا كل محافظات
مصر وخاصه القاهره والاسكندريه الدوله لا
تعرف عنهم اي شيء ولا عن نشاطهم ولا عن
مصادر ارزاقهم ولا
ولا يوردون للدوله مليما واحدا من الضرائب
عشرات الالاف بل مئات الالاف
من المحلات والمصانع اللي بيسموها مصانع
بير السلم اللي هي بعيده عن اي اعم رقابه
والانشطه المختلفه اللي اللي بتدرج تحت
نشاط الاقتصاد غير الرسمي منها على سبيل
المثال عشرات الالاف من المصانع اللي
بتصنع مواد غذائيه مواد تجميل وملابس كل
المصانع ديت بتعمل بعيدا عن رقابه الدوله
وبالتالي الدوله ما بتعرفش عنها حاجه
وتوظف عماله ضخمه جدا لا تدفع اي ضرائب
للدوله كلمه تدفع اي ضرائب للدوله دي
معناها ان ما عندهاش اوراق مكتمله مش
المقصود ان هي ما بتحصلش الضرائب ان
المشكله الوحيده ان ما بتحصلش ضرائب
المشكله ان هذا يعني المؤشر الاساسي ان هي
بعيده تماما عن اعين رقابه الدوله ما يعني
ان منتجاتها لا تخضع لاي مراقبه للجوده عن
هذه المنتجات
بما يحمله من كل الضرر للمواطنين والاخطر
انه هذا خطوره هذا الاقتصاد الكبرى على
للدوله انها حين
تخطط سنويا في لمشروعات التنميه
ولضبط للدوله بتبقى عاجزه عن وضع صوره
دقيقه لانه في 60% طبقا للتقديرات من قوه
العمل تقريبا خارج نطاق هذه المنظومه او
خارج التخطيط في تخطت اكثر تواضعا وبتقول
لا المساله مبالغ فيها ان الاقتصاد غير
الرسمي في في بلد زي مصر على سبيل المثال
مش بتوصل ل 60% لكن بتتجاوز ال 20% سواء
كانت 20% او
60% فده معناه ان في ظاهره ضخمه جدا
هي ايا كان حجمها بتواجه هذا البلد
حين يرغب في التخطيط لمستقبله وحاضره بعض
دراسات بترصد جانب اخر لظاهره الاقتصاد
غير الرسمي وهي فكره اللي عملها فرناندو
سوتو فرناندو سوتو ده اقتصادي من بيرو
وكان وزير ماليه بيرو في منتصف التسعينات
ومشهور جدا بخبرته في ادماج الاقتصاديات
غير الرسميه الانشطه غير الرسميه في
الاقتصاد
الرسمي واجرى حوالي دراسه اجرى دراسه على
امتلات حوالي 20 سنه في مصر بمساعده
اقتصاديين مصريين بقد بيرص جانب اخر لهذه
الظاهره وهو بيرى قبل ما اقول لكم على هذا
الجانب الجديد انه هو اكبر موظف للعماله
في مصر فاذا كان الاقتصاد الرسمي بيوظ
حوالي 6.8 من مليون مواطن فالاقتصاد غير
الرسمي بيوظ حوالي 9.6 من مليون مواطن
يعني هو اكث من الاقتصاد الرسمي بنسبه
كبيره وبرصد كمان حاجه مهمه جدا بيقول انه
اكث من 90% من المصريين والرقم على وجه
التحديد اللي حد حد 92% من المصريين
بيملكه عقارات غير مسجله بشكل كامل لدى
الدوله يعني عقارات اما الدوله بعيده
تماما يعني الدوله ما تعرفش عن اي حاجه
وبالتالي ما بتوصلها اي مرافق الا بشكل
عشوائي ان واحد يبني كده عماره في مكان
ويحصل على الكهرباء والميه بشكل عشوائي او
انه بيحصل على بعض هذه الخدمات نسبيا لكن
مش كل الخدمات لانه مش مستوفي كل الاوراق
وبالتالي لما بيقول غير مستوفي الاوراق هو
ما يقدرش يستخدم بيته كاست ك اصل من
الاصول اللي ممكن يدر عليه ربح بانه يحصل
بموجبه كواحد من الكوتر او واحد من يعني
كضمان لدى البنوك وبالتالي يحصل على ضمان
من البنك ويقدر يوسع مشروع الى اخره ازاي
الدوله ممكن تستفيد الدوله دي اذا كانت
مصر او غيرها من هذا الاقتصاد ازاي ممكن
تدمجه ازاي ممكن تستفيد منه قصه ثانيه
طويله تستحق مننا حلقه ثانيه لكن ابسط
الحلول الى ان
نتحدث في هذه القضيه بتفاصيل اكثر ان
الدوله تتخلى عن منطق الجبايه يعني ما
تجيبش الباعه السريحه وتقول لهم انا عاوز
ادمكم عشان اخد منكم ضرايب ما حدش هيروح
ولكن تحاول بلغه كده اهل البلد تقدم لهم
السبت والاحد والاثنين ان هي تحاول ان
تغريهم بحوافز جيده جدا وبمزايا ان يتم
ادمجهم وبعد ان يتم ادمجهم تحصل منهم في
مقابل الخدمات الكثيره اللي هيح صلوا
عليها حين يتم ادمجهم في الاقتصاد الرسمي
على ضرائب مقبوله بسيطه في البدايه على
الاقل كنوع من التشجيع ليهم انه يكونوا
قطاع منتج ومهم وابسط انواع الضراب ديت ما
يسمى بالضريبه المقطوعه اللي فرضها الوزير
بطرس غالي حين كان وزيرا لماله مصر
الضريبه على سوائل التاكسي وعلى بعض
الصيادله ضريبه مقطوعه يبقى عارف ان هو
يدفع نسبه معينه في اول السنه عند الترخيص
ويمارس نشاطه كما يريد مش الضريبه
المفتوحه اللي بتخوف الناس واللي بيخاف
انه اشتغل طول السنه ومش عارف هيدفع قد
ايه اشكركم ولنا لقاء اخر ان شاء الله